what major
practical changes can a hobbyist who
works regular nine-to-five job do to
improve their Jiu Jitsu so they're in a
gym
there's a lot of excellent gyms
throughout the United States what can
they
do to improve their Jiu Jitsu about
their about the way they think about
just about the way they approach their
actual schedule those kinds of things
that's a great question
okay
the less training time you've got the
more you want to maximize its effect so
a question becomes okay well if I'm
training say twice a week
and sometimes even once a week what can
I do to make sure that that
two hour period is used maximally
um
the less training time you've got the
more the onus is on you to have a plan
before you walk in the door
if you go in just saying
I'm going to roll around and see what
happens or I'll just follow what the
instructor says
you'll get a certain amount out of each
class
but it will never be what it could have
been
go in with a plan
and enact it many people go in with a
plan and don't follow it
let's say for example
we start with the program that goes like
this
first
try to create the most honest assessment
of yourself as a jiu jitsu player
foreign
it's tough to make an honest assessment
of yourself
because you never actually get to see
your game so what I would recommend is
to start by videotaping yourself
inspiring
with your peers
that's fascinating because we don't even
have that level of introspection ability
to reflect of what we actually look like
in grappling start with an assessment of
yourself and the most honest one comes
not from you comes from the camera
have a look at what you see
and start to say okay
many of the weaknesses
in your game are made much more apparent
by looking from the outside in rather
than feeling them during the heat of a
match
identify four or five of the biggest
weaknesses that you see
and start actively attacking those
weaknesses ask yourself let's say for
example
in the course of watching the videotape
of yourself You observe yourself losing
three triangles you attempted three
triangle strangleholds you failed all
three
you could start by saying okay
let me ask myself
who
are the people I look up to the most
with regards a triangle strangle who the
guys who have the best triangle
strangles out there
then ask yourselves
of those people who are the ones whose
body type and personality most closely
mirrors my own
and that would be a good example of
of taking a problem in your game
contrasting it with Elite level
performance of in people whose body type
roughly matches your own and then try to
take lessons you learn by observing the
best people and bringing them into your
own game in one specific area
as time goes by and you do this with
more and more elements of your game you
will undoubtedly improve
you will also have to make sure that you
take time during class to actively work
on these things
now sometimes in class you don't get a
choice the instructor sometimes says
okay today we're working this this and
this but there's always time after and
before class where you can do your own
drilling where you can make your own
inquiries and during sparring
there's no rigorous control over what
you do you can try to work the game into
the areas of focus so for example if you
want to work on front triangles it would
be wise for you to do most of your
sparring from bottom uh guard positions
that'll give you the most opportunity
um
uh and in this sense it always begins
with
an accurate assessment of your current
skill level you've got to start there
then I I always encourage people to use
video camera to make the most honest
honest appraisal you can yeah because
your own mind is not dishonest but it's
understandably inaccurate you tend to
feel things rather than see them when
you're performing jiu jitsu
then make a
a program for yourself based around what
you see as excellence
um
look at the people in the sport who's uh
in in the area you want to work on
people who are renowned for skill in
that area
if possible narrow it down to people who
have excellence in that area and their
body type corresponds with your own
and then try to take lessons learned
from observing the Excellence in these
Elite athletes and bring elements of
them into your game
never try to bring an elite athlete's
entire game to your game that will
create an inauthentic game on your part
which will always be a poor copy of what
you're trying to watch rather bring very
specific areas and skills that you see
and import them from different people
until eventually you find something for
yourself
to experiment a lot okay
everyone's different and so you will
don't see the video research as the
final word see video research the way a
writer will see a muse
as some someone who initiates discussion
opens inquiries for your own research
the most powerful moments you will have
on the mat come from making discoveries
for yourself not being told what to do
not observing someone else doing
something but self-discoveries
those are the ones that will last inside
you so use video research not as the
definitive answer to your problems but
as initiating research for yourself on
the mat
and as time goes by and you do this more
and more often and more and more areas
of the sport I promise you you'll
improve yeah and I I guess when you have
the plan have a plan that carries across
many training sessions so I just
remember I know this is perhaps dumb but
I I saw in my own game early on a lot of
growth it's by self-identifying a
problem
and coming up by myself with the
solution by watching uh in that case
Marcel Garcia I just thought my
butterfly guard was very weak and so I
thought okay what's the solution here I
I thought maybe this x-card thing double
X Card
okay so I watched a bunch of video let
me try to work on this and then all I
did just this itself but uh when I could
get down my by myself meaning like not
instructor guided classes but in
training I would just
every everything I would put myself into
butterfly and ask card and then just let
go like don't progress sweep and figure
out a way to get swapped to get right
back to it back to and everything it was
annoying probably to train with me
because that's all I did and that's all
I thought about right but you learned
quickly yeah I learned it's the most
progress I've ever made now you could
say that xguard wasn't the right
solution for me that maybe that wasn't
the weakest point for me to work on if I
were to look back now it's still to this
day sadly the week the obvious weakest
point of for me is escapes from much
worse positions
that that should be worth on that should
have been worked on from the very
beginning yeah that's still today if I
were to say what's the weakest thing
that I should work on absolutely is even
um
even with one day a week
is escapes but yeah a lot of that has to
do with just uh
carrying like focusing on the one thing
over and over and over and over across
training sessions now it also um
I would write down on the sheet of paper
the number of times I would get an
x-card sweep
and I would set a rule that I have to
get whatever it was like 500 sweeps a
week so I'll have to and then like the
closer you get to the end of the week
the more you like just pick up a small
white 100 in a week yeah so your trading
pot this must suck bro yeah no but no
you start with with good ones and then
you can get more and more desperate
start like finding the the kid right
that you can just sweep over and over
um but like that number for me the
numbers for some reason were like a set
a goal to pull off a technique
um it it enforced like we're staying
with this for a while this is a journey
we're doing and then for some reason for
me that helped me Focus the study to
understand the Deep complexities of this
thing that
um at least for me other people like
nobody at the gym was doing x-guard or
any of that so you have to kind of
figure everything out yourself I'm sure
there's there's better ways to do that
but at least that Focus helps uh from a
hobbyist perspective